un budget identique dans un contexte
économique et social tendu c'est avec
ces éléments que les élus du conseil
départemental ont dû définir les
orientations budgétaires 2016 les
orientations budgétaires quand vous avez
un milliard 500 millions d'euros je
pense qu'il faut quand même dire que
nous fait pas pitié et donc le rôle de
l'élu il est de déterminer où en est le
curseur
est ce que la population et le
territoire de la réunion
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont besoin et donc
c'est nous sommes élus pour cela
donc aujourd'hui nous continuons à faire
des politiques de solidarité pour
accompagner les personnes âgées
nous créons des maisons d'accueil on
familiaux pour aider le réunionnais à
bien vieillir avec son identité créole
nous continuons à les accompagner sur le
chèque santé mais nous avons aussi à
préparer l'avenir
depuis des années le département de la
réunion comme dot département de france
nous sommes confrontés à des difficultés
budgétaires
mais malgré tout parce que nous avons
mis en place un plan d'économie sur nos
chances fonctionnement sur nos
équipements entoure le peut on a mis en
place des économies et cela nous a
permis de supporter ses dépenses die s
de ses dépenses sociales en faveur des
publics en difficulté lesquels dépenses
augmentent chaque année de l'ordre de 30
millions d'euros et les compensations en
provenance de l'état de suivre ce qui
veut dire que nous prenons chaque année
sur nos fonds propres des sous
un budget pour venir en aide aux
personnes âgées aux personnes souffrant
de handicap et aux bénéficiaires du rsa
rien que pour l'année 2016 ce sont 142
millions d'euros que nous allons prendre
sur nos fonds propres ou un c3 dépenses
qui relève d'une de la solidarité
nationale l'année 2016 qui sera l'année
de la mutualisation des moyens notamment
avec l'installation de guichet unique
qui devrait permettre au département et
la région de mettre en commun les
dispositifs et de faciliter ainsi les
démarches administratives des
réunionnais une mutualisation qui passe
par la conférence territoriale des
politiques publiques
région département de la réunion nous
gardons nos dispositifs mais nous
voulons aussi mieux accompagner ceux qui
ont moins une chance c'est pour cela que
la région le département
nous mettons en commun la conférence
territoriale pour avoir non plus des
dispositifs différents où le jeune nico
n'est pas aux seuils faut aller parce
que notre autre apm hellénique au népal
et polis mais un vrai parcours où tous
les dispositifs sont refondus et à aden
ya préfacer le pack jeune il ya le défi
jeunes qui peut aider jusqu'à 30000
euros pour créer son auto-entreprise
tout cela et puis les aides de l'état le
pij qui existent au niveau de l'état les
aides de la région avec la création de
la première entreprise tout cela pour
mieux aider pour simplifier et
accompagner la jeunesse en difficulté
un budget qui sera voté le mois prochain
en séance plénière une matinée qui a
aussi été l'occasion de signer une
convention avec trois collèges qui
s'engage aux côtés de la collectivité à
augmenter les produits locaux dans les
cantines scolaires dans la religion on
incline satellite on n'est pas puisé
centrale donc on va pouvoir commander
parlant des desserts avec sexuellement
est entrée donc avec des produits locaux
et particulièrement ceux de la montagne
avec des vrais dire des producteurs
vraiment vous dirait de très près du
collège on va signer une convention qui
va nous engager vis-à-vis de fournisseur
pour nous approvisionner avec des
produits locaux des fraudes et des
produits frais fruits et légumes une
jeunesse à l'honneur et qui réussit à
l'image de kenji qui a reçu un prix au
dernier festival d'angoulême
une réussite que la présidente du
département et les élus ont tenu à
mettre à l'honneur
depuis j'ai fait la bande dessinée puis
je savais pas je m'attendais à tout sauf
gagné
des du matériel pour faire des sacs
comme chaque année le grand festival de
la bande dessinée d'angoulême bas et
puis
vu un hippocampe dans les plis six
tâches des plus grands dessinateurs de
force très fier très très belle surprise
parce que c'est fait avec un par une
histoire très compliquée un suivi va là
où on s'accroche
kenshin nous a beaucoup donné kenji n'y
reste désormais plus qu'à une chose
dessinée de futurs héros excellence
réunionnais c'est cela aussi que veut
mettre en avant la collectivité kenji en
est l'illustration parfaite et un
exemple pour notre jeunesse